well good evening good to be back
welcome to piers morgan uncensored and
welcome to britain's new prime minister
liz truss i would say congratulations to
mistrust but there's no time for any
celebration this country is in a state
of absolute shambles
inflation is raging energy and food
prices are rocketing thousands if not
tens of thousands of small businesses
face complete ruin millions of families
are waking up wondering how they pay
their bills people are getting poorer
every day they're feeling desperate and
they're feeling they're safe violent
crime is soaring with shocking
consequences nine-year-old olivia pratt
corble shot dead in her own home
pensioner thomas o'halloran who raised
money for charity by busking on the
street killed on his mobility scooter
young kids stabbing each other with
impunity sometimes to death with
machetes
the nhs is in intensive care creaking at
the scene from a pandemic this caused
chronic staff shortages a massive
waiting list union strikes and picket
lines are bringing chaos to our daily
lives illegal migration across the
channel is getting immeasurably worse
not better the ill-conceived rwanda
policy is in tatters
housing is in crisis with rental costs
out of control the pound has crashed to
a 37-year low against the dollar and of
course the ukraine war continues to
cause immeasurable harm to european
economies and security but if ever there
was one symbol of where britain's been
heading it's sort of a torrance of raw
sewage flowing into our seas and onto
our coastlines
forgive my language prime minister but
britain is quite literally turning
so my question is this
what are you going to do about it
a clean break with boris johnson's
disastrous three years of disorder and
deceit would be a good place to start
boris you got brexit done
you crushed jeremy corbyn
you rolled out the vaccine
and you stood up to vladimir putin
you were admired
from kiev to carlisle
did you know that that long prolonged
very awkward silence
never mind from keeve to carlisle boris
johnson isn't even admired by people in
a room full of conservatives
and he didn't get brexit done really did
he he wrapped a bandage around the
northern ireland problem left the wound
untreated
and where exactly are all those promised
benefits of brexit right now the
negatives are a lot more painfully
obvious
boris johnson promised a hell of a lot
and he delivered very little
this trust his campaign has also
promised a hell of a lot including tax
cuts at a time when most economists
think they would be inflation-fuelling
madness
well prime minister now is the time to
get real
britain doesn't need to be told we can
have our cake and eat it anymore there's
no cake left
boris johnson's britain was defined by
complacency chaos and calamity prime
minister trust your brit must be about
solutions integrity hope and honesty
tell us the truth about the mess we're
in tell us the truth about the pain that
lies ahead tell us the truth about what
you're going to do about it that will
actually work
your in trade today must look like the
leaning tower of pisa
your country is on its knees the office
you now hold has been disgraced your
people are angry they're scared and they
need answers right now
you liz trust wanted this job
you spent weeks promising us that you
can fix it you have the solutions well
britain needs you to keep that promise
and keep it fast and will be very
unforgiving if you fail us
[Music]
welcome back to pierce morgan uncensored
uh princess pinocchio is still jabbering
away up in manchester but we have zero
interest in anything she has to say
uh the conservative party that has a
final uh got a new leader and we have a
new prime minister across the country
and yet before liz trust
even meets the queen tomorrow she is
facing talk of a plot to ouster and a
campaign to bring back boris johnson god
forbid with rumors of a new book a
newspaper column plus giddy talk of a
political comeback will boris be a thorn
in liz trust his side is it time for him
to just shove off and button it we're
joining me now political journalist
sinting economist emily sheffield and
former conservative minister and
whitaker well welcome to all of you my
first peers pack of the new season and
you were literally growling at some of
the things unity you know she hasn't
been there five minutes and there's
already this unity and is talking about
who's going to be chancellor vicks jacob
who's going to be home secretary said
actually if she wants to win the next
general election the most significant
appointment from the point of view not
of the country but of the party in
parliament will be the chief whip
because the the party in parliament it's
panic-prone it's chaotic uh it believes
that whatever the opinion polls are
doing today they will certainly be doing
in two years time it has no long-term
perspective and the mere fact that
within two minutes of the prime minister
being chosen they can be talking about
you know plots and ousting i mean it
says it all the problem should stop the
problem she's got is the clock is
ticking to the next election and so with
every day week month that goes by nearer
to that election
mps as we know get very self-serving
very anxious about their own job post
that election and if they think things
are really floundering william hague's
written a column for the times which is
in tomorrow's paper liz trust is the pm
who will either take us through the
gathering storm of domestic and global
crises or we are lost she is the captain
under which the good ship britain will
find a safe harbor or sink i mean my god
this is like
i don't think i've ever read that on a
day one of someone becoming prime
minister but therefore give the captain
a chance rather than what is she saying
rather than
what i'm going to say is give the
captain a chance because if you start
with a mutiny the ship ain't going
anywhere what if the captain is steering
us straight into the titanic we cannot
know that yeah we know she wants to cut
taxes we also know many economists think
that's complete madness but we also know
that some economists do not if you don't
actually give her a chance then for a
certainty the whole margaret thatcher
when she came in big myth that she
actually cut taxes she raised taxes to
start with until she got the economy
back on track then she cut them why
isn't trust doing that truss has made a
very clear point that what she wants to
know she hasn't well may i finish as
what she wants to do
is to stimulate growth now give her the
chance if it fails piers you'll be the
i think this mutiny is being rather
overplayed you've had steve baker today
who is the arch rebel has already come
out saying i'm not going to rebel i've
been doing it for years i'm exhausted i
mean he's not exhausted at all
and i think a lot of the party actually
know it is absolute suicide for the
tories if they mutiny against her it
doesn't mean they're not going to be
silent i agree with you anne but i don't
think you're going to see the kind of
mutiny that you've seen with boris
johnson what you've had with boris
johnson is a a leader who didn't know
how to lead let's face it he did over
some issues i do think his status on
ukraine was correct and vaccines and
vaccines but
i don't think we're in the same period
now brexit is done and we've got an
economic crisis and everyone's saying oh
lizzy's got this terrible entry well she
does but she's also got a single issue
she's got to really solve in the next
two years which is the economy so she
can unite her party behind that if she
wants to win the next election the one
thing she's absolutely got to get right
because no one believes she can fix the
nhs in the next few years is green
shoots that's all she needs to prove by
that here's the problem i think it
doesn't matter who's in charge of the
country right now this is a basket case
situation where almost every metric you
look at for britain right now is a
disaster i mean it's not the way looking
at it look at what's happening with the
pound against a dollar
when i when i was doing america's got
talent as a judge in 2006 seven the
dollar rate from memory was something
like 210 right for every pound you got
two dollars and 10 cents it's now 114
think about that difference i mean i
think about it often i think that some
people on this panel don't think about
that because there have been a few
events over the last 12 years that have
led to that directly namely brexit and
namely 12 years of the tories being in
power and not knowing how to govern the
country properly evidently but look i
think you know liz trust today should
have got up on that podium and finally
revealed what she's going to do for the
millions of people right now who are
looking at the next couple of months and
genuinely don't know how they're going
to pay their bills i think it's so
absurd that we're talking about tax cuts
or give the woman a chance like i don't
care i want money i want to know how how
on earth people are going to pay for
things i just think it's just it just
feels a bit too long i think it's a bit
uh you can't she can't say that
literally as she accepts the crown
because she's not prime minister yet she
could have so she is no but she can't
actually because she's not prime
minister yet she has to meet the queen's
her plans so she's been part of the
government for the last 10 years
this trust has been there for 10 years
she singularly seems to have failed
upwards no one says she was a great
successor all the trade deals when she
was foreign
i don't think you can point to this
trust being a massive success in any of
the jobs she said i'm sorry she's a
massive baby
i don't see i don't see a run of great
successes we go well that person should
be prime minister i see someone who sort
of toddled along in underperforming
governments
ending in this car crash with boris
johnson to which she was very aligned to
him and remains very aligned to him
whether it's brexit to
ukraine
for loyalty well no something well it's
interesting to me
that i don't think she's soon rushed
didn't win this because he was seen to
be the guy who pulled the knife into
boxing
but he was right to wield the knife
boris johnson is right to have gone
richie's soon that was correct now we've
lost probably the the biggest intellect
in that cabinet has now been frozen out
and gone and we have this untrusted
trust that we have to all trust and i'm
just not sure i do trust her no we don't
i'm sure you're i'm sure you didn't
but fundamentally because we don't i
keep being told she's the next maggie
thatcher maggie thatcher would not be
cutting taxes right now if liz trust
tries to cut taxation right now i think
it will be an apocalyptic move by a new
prime minister because it's only just
coming in
to be clear the 1979 manifesto or maybe
too young to remember way too young but
the nice 479 manifesto when thatcher
came in did not mention half the things
that she subsequently did it was very
very broad brush do you think this trust
has it in her to surprise us and to be
bold and dynamic i think she might i'm
not going to say she will i don't have a
crystal ball and only what do we know
about i mean i don't know i don't know
anything after six weeks really i once
asked her on good morning britain i
think what seven times eight was or
something and she spent about five
seconds agonizing it was something but
she froze and panicked that's my only
memory i don't know anything about it we
do know she's quite good at the politics
side because she has won and she played
those members like a like a you know
stroking a purring cat don't you think
louder as she came up with ever more
ridiculous statements i think what we
might see and the tory party might then
rebel in a year the right is she's
promised this very new radical right
agenda
but is she actually going to deliver it
because we don't have her vision yet
every single thing she has said she is
actually already utilized so what's the
deal with the women we don't know
anything about the way she's really i
watched her on laura koonsburg's new uh
show on bbc on sunday and she talks in
this strange robotic
very
people know what i'm talking about
boris you got brexit done
you crushed jeremy corbyn
you rolled out the vaccine
and you stood up to vladimir putin
you were admired from kiev to carlisle
three of those i i can sign up to i
actually voted for boris johnson
precisely to stop jeremy corbyn becoming
prime minister he would have been even
worse so tick on that tick on ukraine
you know i there's a lot of things the
vaccine roller he made a big call with
kate bingham which was proven to be
entirely correct there are things that
you can take in borrows big things yeah
but the damage that was done from the
constant lying the constant dissembling
the constant breach of trust for the
british public culminating in partygate
with half a down history on the lash
every night as we're all kept from
seeing dying loved ones and that's what
you wanted to hear liz trust saying
today well no what i wanted this shot to
do today was was somehow she did the
right thing she praised her predecessor
which is the normal counter why would
you praise someone and then literally
over 50 ministers voted to get rid of
because she actually set out what she
was praising him for and you yourself
have agreed i think she did that and you
yourself have agreed she only won this
race by sucking up to borrow back to
your point about her performance though
because i think we've got to talk about
labour a bit more
that is who she's got to beat at the
next direction and he also is not a
brilliant performer he doesn't have a
huge amount of charisma so it's going to
be quite all right well let me bring a
neighbor on
leaders who are not right
charismatic histamine is quite robotic
as well as a public speaker there's no
question he's not mr charismatic i don't
think he needs to be if i'm kia stammer
right now i'm thinking you know what the
best strategy is sit back and let them
drive this into the titanic yeah but
we've had that strategy for a good two
years from labour and it's the reason
that they're not 20 points ahead in the
polls i mean right now if secure in my
opinion had any sense he'd be out there
calling for
for another general election that's what
he'd be doing but look you know you
watch that speech with liz trust she's
extremely robotic she's extremely boring
i don't think she won over the the
conservative electorate i think those
conservatives as that senior tory mp
told us halfway through this campaign
they would never elect a person of color
and that's what the issue was she won by
default i'm sorry i i won't do it no i'm
not sure i agree with you no i really do
not on the membership i really do not
agree with that you guys i'm very very
fast
although i'm not a conservative or i'm
not in the conservative party anymore
i'm very proud of the fact that in that
election the final two were a woman and
somebody of ethnic origin and the
trouble with labour is talks big about
those things delivers nothing i mean
that is true
the labour party has never had that any
leader who's not a white bloke yeah
correct i mean that's just a fact they
bang on they virtual signal away about
diversity there's absolutely nothing
diverse about labour leadership ever but
i think it's going to be very
interesting on wednesday at pmq's
because
he should really care stammer tear into
her he has got so as you as your opening
to this program broken britain nhs on
its knees social care on its knees six
police forces on special measures
including the met the spate of murders
he has got so much uh ammunition
honestly some young kids but if he
doesn't win the next election she
doesn't deserve somebody was shot i got
back to britain uh on uh two nights ago
and somebody was shot around the corner
in kensington right which is i think the
wealthiest borough in london that we
fought the country and someone was shot
dead in the street near a restaurant
that i go into quite a lot and i was
quite i shouldn't have been shot because
there's violent crime everywhere but it
brought it home to me
britain is getting very violent we are
getting people shot quite regularly
police are ineffective
because because the tories took 20 000
cops off the streets
that's why
there aren't enough of them that is
quite true but also they're focused on
the wrong places they're all focused on
the wrong price party based around law
and order take twenty thousand police
off the streets well the valley madness
the fact is that we have been well we
they have been
cabinet you became the party of lawless
disorder i don't think
well you wouldn't have done probably
that's true